this photo of roman protozovich was
taken
in athens just before he boarded the
ryanair flight for lithuania
he never got there as flight 4978 was
about to cross into lithuanian airspace
it was diverted to minsk because of a
bomb scare
the aircraft was escorted by fighter
jets personally ordered
by the belarussian president alexander
lukashenko
when we received information that there
was a civil aircraft in our airspace
with a possible bomb threat
the operational duty central command
post the air defense was put on high
alert
this was done in order to assess the
situation and subsequently
make the right decision
once on the ground bella russian police
arrested the well-known opposition
journalist
no bomb was found on board we all were
being checked and
they were standing in front of us with
guns and
they were just
well we didn't know what to do because
we we didn't
they were checking our suitcases but at
the same time they were arresting the
journalists roman protozovich runs a
prominent anti-government blog
called nexter
following mass protests against belarus
president lukashenko last year
the belarussian government designated
nexter
an extremist organization and put
protezovic on the most wanted list
he fled to poland for his own safety
they're not offering a safe skies
over which our citizens can fly and we
must therefore
immediately stop overflight of belarus
and
prevent all flights from entering or
leaving that country
we should also immediately ground
bellavia airlines
which is their flag carrier because it
is clearly
not safe for them to fly back to belarus
there has been immediate international
reaction to the incident
the british foreign secretary dominic
raab tweeted that this
outlandish action by lukashenko will
have serious implications
and nato secretary general described it
as a serious and
dangerous incident which requires
international investigation
lukashenko's political rival herself
exiled in lithuania
said that she was in no doubt that the
belarussian president was responsible
today lukashenko personally caused an
international scandal
used military aircraft against civilians
of belarus and european countries
to reprise just one person no one else
is safe
anyone could be in roman protozovich's
place
the ryanair flight has now finally
landed in lithuania
and a criminal investigation has been
opened this incident
will have big international implications
because
in effect the leader of a european
country
has forced a passenger jet out of the
sky
under false pretenses and for his own
political means
aleister bunkel sky news